PROFESSOR: OK,
so, local picture.
It's all about getting
insight into how
the way function looks.
That's what we'll need to get.
These comments now
will be pretty useful.
For this equation you
have one over psi,
d second psi, d x
squared is minus 2 m
over h squared, E minus v of x.
Look how I wrote it, I
put the psi back here,
and that's useful.
Now, there's a whole
lot of discussion--
many textbooks-- about
how the way function
looks, and they say concave
or convex, but it depends.
Let's try to make it very clear
how the wave function looks.
For this we need two regions.
So, the first case, A, is
when the energy minus v of x
is less than 0.
The energy is less than v of
x, that's a forbidden region--
as you can see there--
so it's a classically forbidden.
Not quantum
mechanically forbidden,
but classically forbidden.
What is the main thing about
this classically forbidden
region is that the right
hand side of this equation
is positive.
Now, this gives you
two possibilities.
It may be that psi at some
point is positive, in which case
the second psi must
also be positive,
because psi and the
second psi appear here.
If both are positive,
this is positive.
Or, it may be case two,
that psi is negative,
and the second psi--
the x squared--
it's also negative.
Well, how do we plot this?
Well, you're at some
point x, and here it
is, a positive
wave function seems
to be one type of convexity,
another type of convexity
for a negative, that's why
people get a little confused
about this.
There's a way to see in a way
that there's is no confusion.
Look at this, it's positive,
second derivative positive.
When you think of a second
derivative positive,
I think personally of
a parabola going up.
So, that's how it could look.
The wave function is
positive, up, it's all real.
We're using the thing we
proved at the beginning
of this lecture: you can work
with real things, all real.
So, the wave from here
is x, and here negative.
And the negative
opening parabola,
that's something they got.
So nice.
So, the wave
function at any point
could look like this
if it's positive,
or, it could look like
this if it's negative.
So, it doesn't look like
both, it's not double value.
So, either one or the other.
But, this is easy
to say in words,
it is a shape that is
convex towards the axis.
From the axis it's convex
here and convex there.
So, convex towards the axis.
Now, there's another
possibility I want to just
make sure you visualize this.
Sometimes this looks funny--
doesn't mean actually the way
function can look like that--
but, it's funny because
of the following reason.
It's funny because if you
imagine it going forever,
it doesn't make
sense because you're
in a classically the
forbidden region.
And the way function's
becoming bigger and bigger
is going to blow up.
So, eventually
something has to happen.
But, it can look like this.
So, actually what happens
is that when you're
going to minus infinity--
here is x and we
use minus infinity--
it can look like this.
This is an example of this
piece that is asymptotic,
and it's positive, and the
second derivative is positive.
Or, negative and the second
derivative is negative.
So that's a left asymptote.
Or, you could have
a right asymptote,
and it looks like this.
Again, second derivative
positive, positive wave
function.
Second derivative negative,
negative wave function.
So, you may find this at
the middle of the potential,
but then eventually
something has to take over.
Or, you may find this behavior,
or this behavior, at plus minus
infinity.
But, in any case you are
in a classically forbidden,
you're convex towards the axis.
That's the thing
you should remember.
On the other hand, we can be on
the classically allowed region.
So, let's think of that.
Any questions about the
classically forbidden?
Classically allowed, B. E
minus v of x greater than 0,
classically allowed.
On the right hand side of
the equation is negative.
So, you can have, one,
a psi that is positive,
and a second derivative
that is negative.
Or, two, a psi that is negative,
and a second derivative
that this positive.
So, how does that look?
Well, positive and second
derivative negative,
I think of some wave function
as positive, and negative
is parabolic like that.
And then, negative and
second derivative positive,
it's possible to have this.
The wave function
there it's negative,
but the second
derivative is positive.
These things are not very good--
they're not very
usable asymptotically,
because eventually
if you are like this,
you will cross these points.
And then, if you're still
in the allowed region
you have to shift.
But, this is done nicely in a
sense if you put it together
you can have this.
Suppose all of this is
classically allowed.
Then you can have the wave
function being positive,
the second derivative
being negative,
matching nicely
with the other half.
The second derivative positive,
the wave function negative,
and that's what the
psi function is.
It just goes one after another.
So, that's what
typically things look
in the classically
allowed region.
So, in this case, we say that
it's concave towards the axis.
That's probably
worth remembering.
So, one more case.
The case C, when E is equal to E
minus v of x not is equal to 0.
So, we have the negative,
the positive, 0.
How about when you have
the situation where
the potential at some point
is equal to the energy?
Well, that's the
turning points there--
those were our turning points.
So, this is how x 0
is a turning point.
And, something else happens,
see, the right hand side is 0.
We have that one over
psi, the second psi,
the x squared is equal to 0.
And, if psi is different
from 0, then you
have the second derivative
must be 0 at x not.
And, the second derivative
being 0 is an inflection point.
So, if you have a wave function
that has an inflection point,
you have a sign that you've
reached a turning point.
An inflection point
in a wave function
could be anything like that.
Second derivative
is positive here--
I'm sorry-- is negative here,
second derivative is positive,
this is an inflection point.
It's a point where the
second derivative vanishes.
So, that's an inflection point.
And, it should be remarked
that from that differential
equation, you also get that
the second psi, the x squared,
is equal to E minus v times
psi, which is constant.
And, therefore,
when psi vanishes,
you also get inflection
points automatically
because the second
derivative vanishes.
So, inflection points
also at the nodes.
Turning point is
an inflection point
where you have this situation.
Look here, you have negative
second derivative, positive
second derivative, the
point where the wave
function vanishes and joins them
is an inflection point as well.
Is not the turning point--
turning point are
more interesting--
but inflection points
are more generic.